hollywood harmeyer j.d he's been out in
hollywood since the super bowl
you know what richard said to me about
you jd
he said jd is out partying every night
you wouldn't know his team loss he
should be a whole lot sadder oh get the
[ __ ] out of here idiot kansas city lost
to the tampa bay buccaneers a year ago i
have not been out to dinner i am still
in mourning after a year dude you gotta
slow down on the food listen to this i'm
gonna call this an orgy of eating orgy
of eating
yesterday for breakfast guess what jd
had he had chick-fil-a a sausage egg and
cheese muffin with a hash brown the meal
was 790 calories 52 grams of fat and
1200 milligrams of sodium i mean how old
do you know jd
42 years old yeah i'm telling you dude
stop laughing over there [ __ ]
laughing in my face like an [ __ ]
well john blitt has been very very
serious about following you around and
making sure he uh oh my god i can't look
at this guy every two seconds he's
[ __ ] typing [ __ ] into his phone i
can't [ __ ] live i can't do it hang
around here you're living john yesterday
jd had chinese food for lunch he had
roasted pork fried rice orange chicken
egg rolls and dumplings i mean that is
some of the most fattening [ __ ]
hold on a second it was a whole family
me
a family uh meal thing or whatever yeah
jd ate for a family oh shut up now there
are more people there
i didn't have like all this pork i had
like one of those pork sandwiches about
two
oh all right okay so
but it felt like you know i had you know
a couple a girl you know
whatever what time were you out till
last night at your celebrity
whole other thing john and jd were at a
superstar's home last night they were
invited to dinner natalie means wow
woman who has won multiple grammys she
sold millions of albums has the voice of
an angel somehow she opened her doors up
to jay and jd actually decided to go
natalie texted me uh inviting me over
saying you know i'm having mexican food
and
uh tequila at my place uh you know you
come out and warn welcome to come over
and now how was jd treated is he just a
mere freak sideshow for famous people
and their friends did they bring him
there to laugh at him is that one
or was he one of the was he one of the
celebrities i mean there's an element of
them just totally blown away that this
guy is real they were just amazed and
silent and
just silent and on the edge of their
seats listening to his every word just
waiting and observing and just being in
awe of him that's for sure
they say stuff like
jd can you hoot for us
well the first time he hooted everyone
cheered everyone was like there it is
there it is
and started applauding how much tequila
do you have jd uh i only had a glass of
tequila and two glasses of wine i didn't
even do any edibles or anything that
night no edibles that's not true you did
earlier in the day yeah you did but it
was all i was done with that by the time
you did a five milligram mint and then
on the way over he drank a thc uh
watermelon papaya
like i didn't even finish it
thank god john is there because you
would never get the story lied to us jd
uh started eating before and everyone
sat down but it was a only i was the
first one that [ __ ] no but he didn't
wait for natalie to sit down with her
plate
was halfway through his first
serving before people started eating
what john is explaining to me i really
do have stuff
when you go to a person's home you can't
rush up before everyone eats and be at
the table eating by yourself there were
no i could have swore whatever oh okay
that's what blitz saw that's what
did you like take a [ __ ] at natalie's
house like to make more room i did not
use the bathroom at all excuse me i got
to empty out i just put it delicious
make more room
that's right
what do you got planned tonight oh my
god tonight we are going for a 23 course
omakase at downtown los angeles at a
five-star japanese restaurant i'm also
trying to get jd to come to the pool for
a little hang on yeah i'm not doing a
phone oh yeah he loves the pool yeah no
he doesn't do well in the pool he almost
drowned in that little kiddie pool we
put him in
jd are you afraid uh that paparazzi
would find you by the pool and take
pictures of you and your swimwear no no
no
you know they like to follow a star like
you yeah yeah yeah
you can't miss them
[Laughter]
you guys are like the new cheech and
chong i mean you go everywhere and
you're high and you're eating i do have
video of jd
trying to use chopsticks it's a great
video of him well no i can't get the
things
together i can't do it
i can't walk the chopsticks i
accidentally ate his chopsticks
you know what i'm reminded of jd
remember you couldn't light a lighter
the first time you smoked a joint but
eventually uh the guys taught you how to
live i got it right i got it but you're
having that 23 course meal in a japanese
restaurant you can use chopsticks i need
a fork for my sashimi
ah
let me tell you this guy he's become
quite a sophisticated we all have to
agree that the show oh remember he
hardly would eat anything that we eats
everything
i like bread [ __ ]
[Music]
some cheese it was good
flail fishes
two things of chicken or something
[Music]
i had a roast beef sandwich
that roger crackerville
[Music]
stuff i can heat up in the microwave
[Music]
fettuccine alfredo
it goes down easy
and uh i had diarrhea like the rest of
the day